VAN RIPER: Hi, everyone.
This is Van Riper.
I'm the Google Developer
Groups program
manager here at Google.
And this is our second
edition of Google
Developers Tech Roundup.
And here with me, my
co-host Stephanie.
STEPHANIE LIU: Hi, everyone.
My name is Stephanie Liu.
I also work on the Developer
Relations team, leading the
Global Programs team.
VAN RIPER: And Adriana?
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
Hi, everybody.
I'm Adriana Cerundolo, the
community manager for Google
Developer Groups.
VAN RIPER: And our special
guest today is Fred.
FRED SAUER: Hi, Van.
Thanks for having me,
Stephanie, Adriana.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Google
Cloud Platform team.
I'm really excited
to be here today.
And I have actually a little
demo in store for later, if
you let me.
VAN RIPER: Oh, definitely.
So we thought we'd start off
today, given that we're in the
summer blockbuster season, and
we were talking about movies.
And we started talking about
our favorite hacker movies.
So we thought we'd go around
and talk about what our
favorite hacker movies were.
So how about you, Stephanie?
STEPHANIE LIU: OK, it's the
question of the day.
OK, I won't say that this is one
of my favorites, but it's
definitely the one that has
stuck in my mind the most.
I think it happened during
my formative years.
I saw thin in high school
before perhaps some more
iconic hacker movies.
But it was "Antitrust." I
don't know if you guys
remember Ryan Phillippe.
A young Ryan Phillippe--
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
Cannot go wrong.
STEPHANIE LIU: --as a computer
whiz and like fake Bill Gates
and this whole thing.
And it was action packed.
There was murder and intrigue.
And also I think it was
the first time I
saw a command prompt.
It was like a Unix
command prompt--
he's like hacking the system
from like a daycare or
something--
on a movie screen.
And there's also a nice open
source message at the end.
So I thought it was a
fun, again, kind of
a mainstream computer--
the protagonist being
a computer program.
VAN RIPER: Cool.
What about you, Adriana?
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: I really love
action movies and great
special effects.
So I'm going to have to say
"Tron." So I don't know if
that constitutes technically
the hacker movie.
I feel like it is.
But I totally enjoyed it.
And Jeff Bridges is just an
awesome actor, so you can
never can go wrong with him.
FRED SAUER: So the remake,
not the original "Tron."
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: It's
not a remake.
It's a sequel.
STEPHANIE LIU: Well--.
FRED SAUER: Sequel.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
Yes, the sequel.
I guess I have to go back in
time and actually watch the
original first.
So I'll put that on my list of
things to do this summer.
VAN RIPER: So how
about you, Fred?
FRED SAUER: It's going to
have to be "War Games."
VAN RIPER: Great choice.
FRED SAUER: It's a real easy
one, because it really brings
kind of the computer hacker
culture-- the original meaning
of hacker is not someone
necessarily trying to break
systems, but someone who is
sort of a geek and fiddles
with stuff.
And yeah, they know
how it works.
But he sort of inadvertently
uncovers a government program,
and ends up breaking into
the wrong computer.
And everything's
very physical.
There's a dial up modem.
You hear the squelch
of the dial up.
He has these 5/4 inch floppy
disks the puts
in and loads programs.
There's a number of things in
the movie that aren't quite
real or possible, but
that's kind of OK.
It's on that edge between
Hollywood and reality.
But it's a lot of fun.
It talks about back doors.
And I think it really introduced
a bunch of computer
concepts to the general
audience.
And I've watched
it many times.
So definitely number
one movie.
VAN RIPER: Yeah, that's
definitely one of my favorites.
I guess I'll throw another
one in there.
I also liked "Sneakers." One of
the things in that one is I
thought it, at least, it kind
of portrays them as not just
these nerdy geeks, at least the
head guy, who's played by
Robert Redford as kind
of this cool guy.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Cool guy.
VAN RIPER: Kind of thing.
And actually, the plot of that,
there's some things
about it that, if you think
about it in the context of
current events around the NSA
and what was going on in that
one, it's kind of
a freaky story.
[INAUDIBLE]
paralleled some of the
fictitious stuff that's been
going on lately.
Anyway.
STEPHANIE LIU: So actually, I
ended up watching "Sneakers"--
I only watched it the first
time within the
last five or six years.
And I recognized--
there's a lot of iconic San
Francisco stuff in there,
including the Google
office in SF.
So they do the handoff in the
Hills Plaza building, which is
where we are now.
VAN RIPER: Awesome.
STEPHANIE LIU: Before Google
existed or whatever.
VAN RIPER: What a
good connection.
Awesome.
So we'd love to hear from all
of you what your favorite
movies are.
We're on Google+.
You can just shout out at us
with the hashtag gdtech and
hashtag quoteoftheday,
and share with us
your favorite movies.
Actually, our producer for
today's show, Brian Grady in
the back here, was telling us
that he believes the first
ever hacker movie was "Hot
Millions" in 1968.
So if you know of an earlier
movie than that, let us know.
So with that, I think
we'd like to move on
to a few news items.
I want to preface this by
saying, obviously, this is not
a comprehensive news report.
In fact, even inside of Google,
it's hard for us to
keep track of everything
that's happening.
And that's why we thought it
would be important with this
show to highlight for you a few
interesting things that we
think you may have missed in all
the great happenings going
on here from Google.
So with that, we'll start with
an update from Stephanie.
STEPHANIE LIU: Well, I just
wanted to talk about, I've
been poking around a little
bit with Polymer.
So for those of you who haven't
seen it, it's in a
pre-alpha release.
So people who like living
on the edge.
Definitely check it out.
It's interesting if you
just want to see
where the web is going.
It's a whole bunch of libraries
built on top of Web
Components and trying to
evangelize the use of the
custom element and making
program more declarative.
Again, trying to make web
programming more easier.
Making life easier
for developers.
So again, if you like living
on the edge, check it out.
It's in pre-alpha.
They're looking for feedback.
Give it a look.
VAN RIPER: Sounds good.
And I think you had something
to share as well.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Yeah.
I just want to share the
BigQuery updates I think are
really important.
BigQuery is great
for processing
large amounts of data.
So this is really important
for anyone
who need to do that.
But for new features,
you can output
larger results per query.
So before, you couldn't
do that.
So now, if you have a lot of
data, get ready for some
really large tables.
And then also we can now get
more out of our data.
So we can have new ways to rank
and traverse results and
explore distributions
and percentiles.
So it's really good to have
these new features to more
effectively just get more
information and analysis of
data that we're collecting.
So one great example of this
actually is the Data Sensing
project that we did at
Google I/O this year.
So in the last episode of the
Roundup, we actually had Kim
Cameron from BigQuery
team come in.
And she did a little deep dive
on what the Data Sensing
project was all about.
Go check that out if you haven't
seen that already.
But just the essence of that, in
short, is that we collected
some great environmental data
at Moscone West from I/O and
got some analysis on that
using BigQuery.
So for example, we got the
temperature and air quality
throughout different parts
of the building.
We were able to get the median
temperature over each room.
And then we were also able to
rank, for example, the rooms
by their coldest median temp.
So it's just some fun stuff
that we were able
to get using that.
So also just back to the
updates, just kind of icing on
the cake, too, is that there
is now query caching.
So BigQuery now remembers the
values that you previously
calculated.
It's just going to make
the whole process
a lot easier, simpler.
So great news for all you big
data crunchers out there.
VAN RIPER: Yeah.
So also in the cloud space,
like the big data work, we
recently had some Android
related announcements.
So Android Studio now has
integrated support for
building your backend
applications using Google App
Engine for the backend.
And this is actually another
thing that you'd find on the
Google Cloud Platform blog, as
well as we had just announced
with the BigQuery.
What's really nice about this
is you can manage your
application backend, frontend
all in one place in Android
Studio now.
Especially if you're a Java
developer, and your Java cloud
backend, and take advantage of
the Google Cloud Messaging
that's built in.
You will need, on your account,
to actually set up
enabling Google Cloud
Messaging and
also get an API key.
But once you've done that,
Android Studio takes care of
everything.
Pulls down all the
dependencies.
The App Engine project is
done using Apache Maven.
So it'll pull all your App
Engine dependencies down and
actually pulls down even the
dependencies for Google Cloud
Messaging Support into
your Android App.
So you'll get that
automatically, that
synchronization across
all platforms.
So it's a really exciting
update.
Makes it even easier for the
experienced developer to work
all in one integrated
environment.
And if you're actually a new
developer to App Engine,
Fred's actually going to talk
to us about something that
makes it really easy for
you to get started.
So I'm going to turn it
over to Fred now.
FRED SAUER: OK.
You talked about the Google
Cloud Platform blog.
And actually, just about a week
and a half or so ago, we
did a blog post about the Google
Cloud Playground, which
is something that I've been
working on in my 20% time for
some time now.
And maybe before I show that
you, we should talk a little
bit about the background of
how we kind of got there.
I've been working on App Engine
for the last four and a
half years or so.
And one sort of consistent piece
of feedback I get from
developers who are on the
platform is, we really like
the platform.
We like the productivity.
It's just so nice not to have
to manage machines.
People, once they buy into
or start using a managed
platform, they really don't
want to go back into doing
things themselves.
At the same time, when I talk to
new developers, I find that
there's a big kind of hurdle
to that first Hello World
program, if you will, where
you're trying to get your
environment set up,
these new tools.
And you just want to figure
out how to run the thing
end-to-end, and you get
those two simple
words on the screen--
Hello World.
And so taking a step back,
looking at these two different
stories, it really feels like
we're sort of asking
developers to make an investment
in our platform.
Download this stuff.
Get it installed.
Deal with the software
conflicts,
administrative rights.
Do all that stuff.
And maybe that takes
you half an hour.
Maybe you spend four or five
hours on it, because there's
something weird going on
with your machine.
So we're asking you
to invest first.
And then we're telling you,
surely you'll fall in love.
And it seems a little bit
backwards to do it that way.
I feel like maybe you should
go on a date first or you
should have a chance to fall in
love before you make that
commitment, net investment.
So with that in mind, I thought,
well, how can I bring
dating to the Cloud platform
and particularly to--
let's start with App Engine,
because I've been working
there a long time.
So right here on this Chrome
Book, I've brought up the App
Engine documentation, the
Getting Started Guide.
And along with that blog post,
we launched these little green
buttons onto the
Getting Started
documentation for Python.
And this is sort of the
Try Me Out button.
The let's go on a date, a
quick 60-second date.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
[INAUDIBLE].
FRED SAUER: Let's go have
a root beer float.
Let's go together.
STEPHANIE LIU: Fred is building
dating applications.
[LAUGHTER]
FRED SAUER: And the button's
green, so let's click on that.
And what it does, it takes
you right into the Cloud
Playground here, loads up
the same source code.
And let me just enlarge
that a bit for you.
And this is our Hello World
sample code that
we tell you to use.
And with one click, I can see
the output, and I can see
Hello World right there.
Now that was a lot easier than
configuring a machine and
downloading software, and am I
doing it right, and watching a
bunch of YouTube videos.
And could go on and on about how
long it takes to get here.
And I get this realtime
experience.
So let's change the code.
Let's say, Hello Tech Roundup.
Oh, and we need a hashtag.
So gdtech, right?
VAN RIPER: Or we'll put
a little yee haa.
[LAUGHTER]
VAN RIPER: Sorry.
FRED SAUER: We could.
We could.
If only we could add
sound effects.
That's a future request
right there.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Let's
just put that in the
queue for next time.
FRED SAUER: Very good.
So we've done Hello World, and
now you want to take it maybe
a step further.
The drink's going well, and now
let's order an appetizer
or something else.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Dinner
maybe, you know?
FRED SAUER: Maybe
a full dinner.
Let's go back to the
main screen.
So I just clicked on the
Cloud Playground there.
And I'm going to take our next
App, which is the Guest Book.
And we pop into that project,
and we have a look there.
Let's just run it and see
what it looks like.
And there's our Guest Book.
Pretty simple application.
If you walk through our
documentation, and you go
through the different steps, at
the end, you're Hello World
is transformed into
a Guest Book.
So this is exactly kind of the
Getting Started experience,
but a little bit accelerated
for this speed dating
experience.
So let's sign our Guest Book.
I'm the first visitor here.
And so I'm going to sign
it with my name.
This is actually persisting this
data into the App Engine
Data Store, zero
configuration.
App Engine is replicating this
data to multiple data centers.
If a meteor comes down and hits
one of the data centers,
my app still keeps running.
It's kind of amazing technology,
and it's all
behind this little
green button.
VAN RIPER: The Easy button.
FRED SAUER: The Easy button.
So that's it.
It's a really simple demo.
But you can see how you
can play around with
the real APIs here.
You can try out URL Fetch and
connect to another service on
the internet.
You can try the users API,
see what Auth looks like.
You can play with the App
Engine Data Store.
You can even configure Cloud
SQL to play with
a relational database.
There's just any number
of APIs that you
can use on App Engine.
You can try them out here.
And then once you're really
invested and you
say, you know what?
This is a great experience.
I would like to take
it up a level.
I want to download the
tools, and I want to
be productive offline.
That's still there.
VAN RIPER: Sounds great.
Did you have some questions?
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
I do, actually.
So what will be the next
languages that will be
available then after Python?
FRED SAUER: That's a
very good question.
That's kind of a persistent
question on
the App Engine team.
We just launched the
PHP runtime.
We'd had already have an
experimental Go runtime.
In production, we have Python
2.7 and Java runtimes.
So that's a pretty
good question.
The Cloud Playground I started
with Python 2.7, because that
was just the easiest
thing to do.
Python is a scripted language
where you can
evaluate source code.
So it's really easy to kind
of create this Playground
experience, because I can take
your source code and just pass
it to an eval function,
and viola, it's there.
With compile languages like Java
and Go, there's obviously
a compile step.
And so that requires a
little bit more work.
And I've been sort of looking
at that since our blog post
went out and thinking maybe I
can use Compute Engine to
combine with App Engine and kind
of do this compile step.
But what was interesting is the
blog post went out, and
that same day, I had two or
three people walk into my
office and say, how do we
get my language going?
I had the Go there, the
Java guy there.
I even had Seth, the
Dart guy there.
He's like, can I run Dart?
Maybe so.
Let's see what we can do
in the Playground.
With a Compute Engine
instance, it's a
regular Linux VM.
You can run any software
you want.
You can compile it.
Maybe we can create some really
cool experiences.
I'm also looking for feedback
from the community.
Like what's the most interesting
thing to do next?
What would make people
the most productive?
VAN RIPER: So Google Compute
Engine is one of the building
blocks that makes this
all possible?
FRED SAUER: Currently this
is just App Engine.
But if I were to expand it and
include Compute Engine, then
the capabilities really
get expanded there.
And combining the two has a lot
of benefits, because App
Engine allows this kind
of managed platform.
Instances are scaled up
automatically for you.
You don't have to worry
about a lot of things.
And Compute Engine gives you
this flexibility to run
arbitrary binary code.
So combining those two things,
maybe together with some APIs
to allow you to deploy like a
private version of Playground
so that you can play around with
just your source code,
it's all possible.
STEPHANIE LIU: So you've touched
on the architecture,
like the backend architecture
a little bit.
So one of the questions from the
Google Moderator that we
sent out when we
were staying in
Colorado was about AngularJS.
So do you want to talk a little
bit about the frontend
of how you built this?
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
So the Cloud Playground right
now is kind of a stack, a
two-layer cake, if you will.
A two-layer desert cake.
The bottom layer is this
evaluation layer that just
takes your source code and
executes it, and gives you the
results back.
And it's the part in this demo
that displays this bottom
green box here.
That's where the output is.
And there's no real UI for it.
It's just running your code.
And that piece, in the Open
Source Repository that was
called Mimic.
Because it's trying to mimic a
real application environment,
doing some tricks.
On top of that, the top layer
of the cake or the icing, is
this user interface.
And that's the Cloud Playground,
everything that
you've seen in the demo.
And its an AngularJS app,
because Angular's just really
easy for building web
applications.
And one thing that I really
like about Angular is that
when you view source--
and let's do that right here
and actually let's grab the
project page.
Maybe the main page,
the main HTML page.
So typically when you're
building web applications, you
would have some sort
of templating
language on the server.
And the server would take
whatever code you've written
in some template-- maybe it's
Django, maybe it's Jinja2,
maybe it's something
else, GSPs--
translated to HTML, send it down
to the browser, and the
browser would interpret it.
And so as a developer, you're
always doing this mental math
or this mental transformation,
where you're looking at the
template language and you're
trying to imagine in your head
what the HTML is going
to look like.
And then what the browser is
going to do with that HTML and
then what the UI is going
to look like.
And so you're sort of always
one level removed from the
actual HTML that you're
trying to build, which
is the native language.
So if you look at an Angular
HTML page and you look at the
source code, you can
actually read it.
It is the template itself.
So right here, I just search
for this Angular expression
called ng-repeat, which tells it
to repeat certain elements.
So you see here I have a
heading, which is My Projects.
And then I have this
table with a
table row that's repeated.
And it's repeated once for every
project that I have.
So what does that look like?
That's right here, these
two projects.
These are two rows
in the table.
And so I can look at this code,
and I can write all my
HTML, and I don't have to do
this kind of mental math.
VAN RIPER: You can actually
look at that on a browser.
FRED SAUER: You can
look in a browser.
VAN RIPER: All the data isn't
there, but you get some sample
data in what you've done.
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
So you can debug applications.
And I think one of the tag
lines, to kind of paraphrase
it for AngularJS, is it's the
HTML development experience if
HTML had been written for
dynamic web applications.
And I think that really kind of
sums it up for me, is that
HTML was designed
for static apps.
We've done all these hacks
to make it dynamic.
But once you throw in Angular,
it feels like you're in a
natural development environment,
and you want to
build more apps.
And that's, ultimately, I think
what we're out and about
in Google Developer Relations,
is making the development
experience really good
for developers.
Having that best experience for
your productive, you're
building stuff, you want
to build more stuff.
Getting that excitement
back into development.
That's what Angular is about.
And that's what the Cloud
Playground's about.
STEPHANIE LIU: So going back to
architecture a little bit.
We had the Python,
Ruby, JavaScript
evaluators in the browser.
It has been really great.
What were some of the
main challenges?
Was your approach any different
than some of those
evaluators?
FRED SAUER: It was.
I looked at a lot of different
playgrounds.
You have, obviously, the sites
like jsFiddle that allow you
to manipulate some JavaScript,
HTML, and CSS and sort of try
out widgets or little things
in a web browser.
There's a lot of tools out there
that lets you evaluate a
snippet of code in a web
browser, GoLang, for example.
If you look at the Google I/O
concurrency slides, there's a
nice little HTML 5 slide deck
with code snippets and a
little Run button.
And every time you click Run,
the code executes in the
server, and you see
the results.
And you can kind of interact
with the code.
Even the GoLang tour.
The Dart language has similar
tour where you can go through
and edit code in the
browser and run it.
But almost all of these
Playgrounds
are our snippet based.
They're sort of about
learning the
fundamentals of the language.
What does print do or print F?
Or how do I calculate
Fibonacci numbers?
Or how do I do simple stuff?
But none of them are--
as soon as you want to go to
something more, you end up on
the other end of the spectrum
with kind of a full-fledged
cloud development experience,
a cloud IDE.
like Codenvy or what's
the other one?
STEPHANIE LIU: Cloud9?
VAN RIPER: Dev?
FRED SAUER: DevTable.
Yes, DevTable's the other.
Just two of the ones that come
to mind that have kind of App
Engine integration.
So on the one end of the
experience, you have these
little snippets.
Let's learn the language.
The other end, you have the
cloud IDE or desktop IDE,
which is a full rich
environment.
Lots of functionality,
lots of productivity.
But there's kind of a steep
learning curve.
And there was very little
in between.
And that's where the Cloud
Playground tries to fit.
It gives you access to sort
of many projects.
So here, I have four different
source files in my project.
And I can play around
with that.
I can have one file here.
This is my Python file where
the code executes.
And I have this index
of HTML, which is
my server side template.
Old-fashioned way of
using Angular.
So we're trying to strike this
balance of let's get you doing
something simple like Hello
World, a Guest Book, something
more than a trivial snippet of
code, without the learning
curve required once you go
to a full development.
VAN RIPER: So that kind of is
half an answer to my next
question, which is going to
be some people were asking
whether you have integration for
cloud-based code editors
like Codenvy?
FRED SAUER: I haven't really
thought a lot about it.
But I think that's something
that's really interesting.
Because what I showed here was
sort of the, I'm reading about
App Engine from the
documentation.
Let's upgrade me to a place
where I can edit code snippets
or tiny little projects.
And the natural extension to
that is, let's say I play
around with this for a couple
hours, and I'm actually
starting to build something
interesting or I want to do
some tighter integration with
mobile, and I want to use
Cloud Endpoints.
Or I'm just doing more, and I'm
starting to get invested
in the platform.
How do I take what I've
built so far and move
onto the next step?
So one easy way to do that might
be to have a download my
sources zip or push it to a get
repository so I can play
around with it.
But I think another great option
would be let's export
it to Codenvy.
And let's upgrade my experience
from this
Playground to a full-fledged
IDE.
STEPHANIE LIU: Is that
like going steady?
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
VAN RIPER: It's gone past
the dating stage.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
It's like getting engaged.
STEPHANIE LIU: Let's see
how long we take
this metaphor out.
Keep it getting.
FRED SAUER: I think when you
push your code to production--
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: You're now
watching movies at home, when
you're on the couch.
FRED SAUER: I think when you
ultimately push your code to
production and do a full deploy,
I think that's like
getting married.
[LAUGHTER]
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: That
was a good run.
STEPHANIE LIU: Then we took
it all the way to the end.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: We did.
VAN RIPER: And that does bring
us to the end, I think.
STEPHANIE LIU: Did you have
any final thoughts?
You mentioned feedback
a little earlier.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, I'd love
to get feedback.
Maybe the best place is on the
blog post on the Google Cloud
Platform, just comments there.
Reach out via email,
of course, is
always great as well.
Just discussion online.
I'd love to see what people
build and then also would
really like to hear where we
should go next with the Cloud
[INAUDIBLE].
VAN RIPER: Great.
So all the things we talked
about today, we'll have links
in the show notes and stuff.
I was going to do a few quick
shout outs before we end this
week's show.
As was mentioned, Codenvy,
we recently had some
announcements about the third
party ability to edit code on
Chrome Books in the cloud.
So you should check that out,
especially if you're a Chrome
Book or Chrome Pixel,
like Fred is.
As some of you may know, we
recently had the two-year
birthday celebration
for Google+.
That was June 28 in 2011
that it was launched.
And Chris Messina has a nice
post on G+, of course.
Properly hashtagged, I assume.
And that will be in
the notes as well.
And then I wanted to end with
a shout out particularly for
our community folks, the Google
Developer Groups.
There was this recent Android
Developer Days
in Ankara in Turkey.
But it wasn't just the
GDGs in Turkey.
There were actually 14 separate
GDGs from multiple
countries that collaborated on
bringing together the Android
Developer Days in Ankara, and
there were more than 1,000
participants.
So that really deserves a
special shout out in terms of
community development efforts.
And if you would like your
community efforts, your
developer-- it doesn't have to
be a Google Developer Group.
Just Google Developer
related technology.
You can kind of shout out to
us on Google+ with the
hashtags gdtech about it.
We're going to end with a
magic moment from the
Developer Days in Ankara,
a photo from there.
And if you'd like to see your
photos at the end of some
future segment, just add the
gdtech hashtag and hashtag
magic for magic moments.
And with that, I think
call it a wrap.
FRED SAUER: I think
that's a wrap.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
That's a wrap.
STEPHANIE LIU: Totally.
VAN RIPER: [WHIP  SOUND]
[MUSIC PLAYING]